so as you can imagine everybody in
politics and at the federal level was
asked a lot of questions by people in
the media
what was yesterday like what does it all
mean
rather than doing a bunch of interviews
i thought i'd give a
my view of what happened yesterday and
the way forward for the country
and try to get back to south carolina
and
and help the transition here the first
thing that stands out to me
is how embarrassed and disgusted i am
that the united states capitol could be
taken over by domestic terrorists
while we're in session transferring
power from one president to the other
that a band of people who are
terrorists not patriots literally
occupied the floor of the house
drove the senate out of its chamber and
the question for the country is how
could that happen
20 years after 9 11.
september this year will be the 20th
anniversary of the attack on our nation
it is mind-boggling that such an event
could occur
senator schumer's call for the secretary
sergeant of arms the senate to resign
i echo that anyone in charge
of defending the capital
anyone in charge of defending the
capitol failed
uh in their duties if they would have
been in the military they had been
relieved of their commands and
most likely court-martialed so the first
thing that has to happen
is to hold those accountable for failing
to defend the nation's capital
while the congress was in session
why am i worried it would have been so
easy
for a terrorist organization to
infiltrate this movement
the lone wolf terrorist i think we've
got a pretty good grip on
but political protest in this country is
the heart and soul of who we are
but we haven't been protesting lately
we've been burning down
cities we've been attacking federal
courthouses
we've been looting in the name of social
justice
and now we've occupied the capital this
needs to stop
to my democratic colleagues i share your
disgust
and embarrassment and determination
to make sure that what happened in our
capital never happens again
but you need to speak up when this
happens in other places
lawliness lawlessness in one place
breeds lawlessness everywhere when one
cause
resorts devour violence and people are
not prosecuted
other causes believe maybe this is okay
so the mistake we made is when people
tried to destroy the
courthouse in portland they weren't
prosecuted
to the full extent of law when they
occupied seattle
they weren't prosecuted to the full
extent of the law
when the attack the the acceptance of
the nomination
by president trump here in d.c
virtually no one was prosecuted
it's good to hear everybody wanting
prosecutions
some are late to the dance i was there
from day one
so let's reset and move forward
until every political movement out there
no matter how just your calls in your
own mind
using violence will not advance your
cause
it will only lead to your personal
incarceration
or if you go too far to injury so what
am i calling for i'm calling for a joint
task force to be
assembled and spend
all the time and money necessary to
identify
every person who breached the security
of the capitol
who occupied the chambers
who invaded offices and destroyed
property
there's a ton of video evidence out
there
i was interviewed this morning by two
fbi agents
they came to my house wanting to know if
i had any surveillance
cameras outside my house i did not but
i'm encouraged they're on the case
trust me in the social media world it
exists today it will be not
won't be that hard to find thousands of
people
who took the law in their own hands the
people sitting in the chairs
need to be sitting in a jail cell
the people who attacked the capitol
police need to be charged
with attacking a police officer sedition
may be a charge for some of these people
so i will for the next six years god
willing
every week ask of the department of
justice starting with this department of
justice
and the next department justice what
kind of progress are you making
in holding those accountable the
domestic terrorists
who took over the house and the senate
chambers and laid waste
to capitol hill what do you need that
you don't have
if you need more prosecutors money will
not be an object
if you need more investigators we'll
provide you the resources
this is a moment for the nation to show
will and determination
to be a nation of laws that anarchy
shall not reign
the constitution controls not the mob
yesterday i was proud of senator
mcconnell the republican leader of the
senate
who stood up and called for a peaceful
transfer of power
to vice president biden and kamala
harris like
senator mcconnell i supported president
trump
i've become close to the president
personally
i think as president has been
consequential from a conservative point
of view
it has been an amazing four years in
terms of judges
securing the border a vaccine in record
time
deregulating the economy cutting taxes
historic mideast peace agreements the
destruction of the caliphate
on and on and on was tarnished by
yesterday
when it comes to accountability the
president needs to understand
that his actions were the problem not
the solution
that the rally yesterday was unseemly
it got out of hand and a good friend of
mine rudy giuliani did not help
i said on the floor of the senate i cast
my vote accordingly
that joe biden is the legitimate
president-elect of the united states
are there irregularities in this
election yes i'm sure they are
have they been overblown absolutely
there's been a constant effort
by people from the president's legal
team to provide misinformation
to distort the facts to make accusations
that could not be proven
that needs to stop as to the 25th
amendment being invoked
i do not believe that's appropriate at
this point
i'm looking for a peaceful transfer of
power i'm looking for the next 14
days to reset and we will hand off power
in a traditional sense
by being a peaceful transfer i talked to
mark meadows this morning
the transition is going well is
fully in place i talked to the
president's legal counsel pat sipoloni
he is doing everything he can to help
the transfer
occur as to to these two gentlemen
most americans will never know the
service
that mark meadows and pat cipoloni and
their
those under their charge provided to
this country
over the last year talk to secretary
mnuchin today
who's in israel no one will fully
understand
what he and others have brought to the
table
so to those who believe you should leave
your post now
to make a statement i would urge you not
to robert o'brien
you've been getting a good counsel to
the president you've been a steady hand
i've been missing your phone calls
robert stay on
to those in the national security
apparatus we need you now more than ever
so i embrace joe manchin's statement
i talked to joe this morning he has
called for those
around the president to stay in place to
ensure that we can have a peaceful
efficient transfer of power
why do i say that joe biden is the
legitimate president of the united
states
because he got the most votes the state
certified him the winner enough to get
over 300 electoral votes and all you
need is 270.
to my colleagues who objected yesterday
you didn't do
anything illegal the law allows you to
do what you did
i respect your ability to do it i
disagreed with what you were trying to
do
one member of my conference said we
can't turn a
blind eye to the problems in this
election
i will tell the american people there
has not been
a blind eye turned
the allegations about the law being
broken
in wisconsin that they changed election
law
contrary to the wisconsin constitution
picasso coven
was litigated by the wisconsin supreme
court they ruled four to three
that what happened was legal al gore
accepted a 5-4 decision by the u.s
supreme court to end his litigation to
be president united states
my job is not to overturn
the wisconsin supreme court the
allegations about the consent decree
in georgia changing georgia law
unconstitutionally were litigated in
federal court
and the trump team lost
the people on the campaign legal team
have made accusations without sufficient
proof
they have been more of the problem than
the solution
they have claimed that 66 000 people
in georgia voted under 18. i have not
found one person
they have claimed that 8 000 felons
voted from prison in arizona
i've asked for a list of names and
received none this
needs to end a blind eye was not
turned the outcome that was reached
was disappointing to those of us who
supported the president
but it was done through the lawful
process of challenging courts
court challenges and actually having
hearings with the legislative bodies
of these swing states not one judge
anywhere in the land accepted the
accusations
to be legitimate and not one legislative
body
in the states in question decided to
change the certification
after hearing the accusations
the congress job is not
to overturn elections that we disagree
with the congress's job
is to count the votes sent in by the
states
that were lawfully certified and declare
the one with the most votes the winner
president and vice president as to mike
pence
in this debacle of the last week or so
there's one person to me that stands out
above all others
and that is vice president mike pence
the things
said about him
the things he were he was asked to do in
the name of loyalty
were over the top unconstitutional
illegal and would have been wrong for
the country
mike pence faithfully fulfilled the duty
assigned to any vice president to count
the votes and declare the winner
to those who would wish that the vice
president united states could send
electoral votes back to the states
because they believe fraud was involved
be careful what you wish for do you
really believe it's good
in america for a single person to have
that power
do you think the 12th amendment gives
that power absolutely not
so what's so disappointing to me is that
people who have prided themselves on
being constitutional conservatives
were pushing this bizarre theory
so i just want every republican to know
that in my view limited government
applies when you don't like the outcome
just as much as when limited government
applies and you do like the outcome
the constitution needs to be followed as
written
even though you wish you could do
something the constitution does not
allow
to get your way that's the very essence
of
activism to those who were pushing
the idea that vice president pence had
the power
to unilaterally set aside certified
electoral votes from a single state or
send them back
you have cheapened the idea
of constitutional conservatism so when
asked
to do something against conservative
values
that would be harmful to the nation mike
pence
said no
other people chose this moment to
advance
their personal causes i have found in
this job
over time moments like this
come back to haunt you if you're doing
something you shouldn't be doing so
january the 20th i intend to be there
i am hoping that president trump will
allow his team
to continue to work closely with the
biden
transition team to transfer power
peacefully
that president trump will focus on some
of the achievements he has accomplished
remind the country of the consequential
presidency he has had
except that he fell short
and a new president will be coming and
to
turn down the rhetoric and allow us as a
nation
to heal and move forward to my
democratic colleagues
i ask the same of you that i'll take
questions
senator graham you were one of president
trump's biggest critics
during the in 2016 election then he
became one of his biggest supporters
do you have any regrets in your support
of him and what this has led to at this
moment
uh no i was a
opponent of president trump and i got
beat like a drum
i didn't scratch i had a decision to
make
i said everything i could think about
regarding him as a candidate
the people of south carolina spoke he
won my stadium became president united
states
so i decided then it's not about me
it's about my job as being a senator
from south carolina
people from south carolina wanted me to
work with this president and i did
i did the same with obama i'll do the
same with biden
but this is a republican president he
changed my opinion
of who he was through his actions
yesterday though and helped inside of
mob right yes let me get there
the reason i have been close to the
president
is i think he's done tremendous things
for this country
i think the judges he has nominated have
been
outstanding choices and we saw yesterday
an independent judiciary i think
people like bill barr were were the best
people in the country to be attorney
general at the time they were
i think what he did to destroy the
caliphate was long overdue it makes it
safer
i think getting out of the iran nuclear
agreement has led the way
to peace between the arabs and the
israelis at a level
i would never imagined i think he's
brought
order to the border he listened to me
he asked my advice about judges when i
got
upset about syria he listened and he
actually
changed his policies i could never get
obama to do that
obama had a good relationship with him
but was senator mccain we begged him do
not leave iraq
but he did as to yesterday
it breaks my heart that my friend a
president of a consequence
would allow yesterday to happen and it
will
be a major part of his presidency
it was a self-inflicted wound it was
going too far
and here's the one thing i can say the
next two weeks
can begin to right the ship depending on
how the president behaves
and over time his presidency will be
viewed
in a fuller context i have absolutely
no regrets of helping this president
make us safer more prosperous i've
enjoyed my relationship with him
i say these things not because of
animosity
i say these things because i have to
but senator graham
after being so close to this president
for four years
do you think that you and other
republicans had more of a responsibility
to speak
out both privately and publicly when he
said things that were untrue when he
ginned up his base do you think that
that would have made a difference
yesterday
i think the trump presidency
has been poorly covered by people in
your business
i think that from the time he took
office
there's been an effort to cover his
presidency
in a way that i think is not helpful to
the country i have spoken up
there has been an effort to believe
everything that trump did was wrong
before it's proven or not
all i can say is that i have shared my
thoughts for the president i've spoken
out when i thought i should
but the one thing that i want you to
know there are plenty of republicans
believe
that the trump presidency was never
legitimate in the eyes of the democratic
party
never accepted by the people in your
business and it's been a constant
drumbeat
and uh i think that's taken a toll on
all of us
so could i have done better yes the
question could you have done better
could those of you who cover the white
house done better you need to ask
yourself that
on that senator if i just follow up on
that really quickly you didn't
acknowledge joe biden as president of
this united states for
a month and a half didn't that
contribute to the notion among the
christians
i think that is i think that is exactly
the problem
did anybody doubt that
vice president gore did you ask any
democrat why don't you acknowledge
that vice president gore lost you waited
till the results were in of the
litigation
no it's not no it's a president going to
court
challenging results
from the time the race was called
i was hounded why don't you say
biden won you wanted me to declare biden
the winner
before president trump had the right to
go to court
and exercise the same rights other
presidents have had
and i chose not to do that i said last
night joe biden is the president
he won the constitution worked
you just said that vice president pence
was asked to do things that were illegal
and unconstitutional he was asked to do
those things
by the president publicly so why
shouldn't the
25th amendment be used if the president
asked the vice president to do things
that were illegal
yeah i think what the president was
asking of the vice president
was not constitutionally allowed he had
people who said
that he could do it the fault lies i
think with some of the legal
advice around it you've had people in
his legal team
make claims that are just beyond the
pill the president's frustrated he
thought he was cheated
nobody's ever going to convince him that
he wasn't but this
idea of asking the vice president to use
his powers
to send back electors that were
certified doesn't exist in the
constitution
the president like just isn't the boxed
off somewhere else
do you trust the president not to incite
the kind of violence that he promoted
yesterday in the next two weeks
i'm hoping he won't i'm hoping that he
will
allow mark meadows to continue with the
transition
they will start talking more about what
he's done as president
focus on the threats we have coming from
iran
finish out the next 14 days in a way
that will allow us to get a good start
for vice president biden that it does
him no good in my view now to continue
to attack the legitimacy of the election
because this election was legitimate and
it has now been decided constitutionally
so my hope is that we can move forward
in the next 14 days
but this will depend on what the
president does i am hopeful that the
worst is behind us and we can
transfer power on january 20. what gives
you that hope
have you spoken anymore i talked with i
talked with
some people this morning um that
seems to be a belief that we're moving
in the right direction
and i'm just trying to reinforce that
the people around him
i think have the right attitude the
people around him i think are giving him
good advice it's up the president take
it
and again uh you asked me about my
relationship with the president i regret
it not one bit
i think we've had a hell of a ride we've
done some great things for the country
i hate it it ends this way senator do
you believe that
the events of yesterday disqualify the
president from seeking the office again
in the future i'm not worried about
the next election i'm worried about
getting through the next 14 days
um we'll talk about 2022 and 2024.
let's get uh vice president biden sworn
in january the 20th
and i'll make an observation politically
uh if you're a republican
been tough couple weeks we lost georgia
two good candidates fell
short i'm confident that from what i
hear the democrats are going to
overreach
if we can regroup rebuild ourselves get
away from the fiery rhetoric and
the conspiracy theories that we'll have
a chance in 2022 to take back the senate
and take back the house but it's going
to require us to go back to the blocking
and tackling of conservative politics
they're not only talking about 25th
amendment both leader schumer
and speaker pelosi have used the word
talk about impeachment pursuing
impeachment can you just respond to what
yeah i mean i
i don't remember either one of them
speaking up
a whole lot during other crisis
i mean i like them both but when they
were burning portland down
in seattle they never said a word when
they were attacking rand paul they never
said a word
the guy that sort of stood out to me was
joe biden
i thought joe biden did a really good
job yesterday
of talking about how bad this is and we
need to get it behind us
and i'm telling you as a republican i
don't support an effort to invoke the
25th amendment
now if something else happens
all options would be on the table but i
i see
i hear from schumer and pelosi
just political talk what kind of
role do you think that president trump
should take in the next 13 days should
he be more public he's been banned from
some
social well suspended from some social
media platforms and what kind of
role would you like to see vice
president pence play
well i'd like to see president trump
help unify the country
i don't know if he's going to come to
the inaugurations up to him i wish he
would
i wish you would come and acknowledge
that the transfer of powers has occurred
but that will be up to
president trump he shouldn't come unless
he feels like it's the right thing to do
for the country
things like that would go a long way i
think he should talk
about what he's done i think he should
focus on some policy achievements
then and and basically let the biden
administration know
that i have secured the border here's
how i've secured it
if you change these policies we're going
to go back to chaos
i think he should talk about how we've
gotten all these peace agreements
between the arabs and the israelis
that's by being tough on iran
i think he should explain to the
american people the successes of his
policies
and that not only will be helpful to
vice president biden soon to be
president biden
but he will have a responsibility if he
changes those policies
if i were the president i would
highlight what i've been able to do at
the border
and explain to the bible administration
this worked
how did we get these peace agreements
between these arab nations
and israel how can you do more
why do you think he can't do that do you
believe after spending so much time with
him that he is
mentally unwell as some of his aides
have said
i think he's very frustrated he thinks
the election were stolen
i think he's got some very bad advisors
around him
that push ideas that are not sound i
think the president
has got good people around him now i
think mark meadows and pat sipoloni and
others are giving him good counsel and
good advice
i am here today to answer your questions
to say
what i think i think the best thing the
president can do
is encourage a transition to be peaceful
to be professional and to use the voice
he has in the next 14 days
to talk about his successes and to bring
us together
he has a voice and i would like him to
use that voice
to bring us together and to focus on his
accomplishments
and uh we're going to soon have a new
president
i promise to work with vice president
biden to the extent i can
there's things we can do and there are
things we're not going to be able to do
the last four years what makes you think
you can do it in the last 14 days and
bring people together well i think he
has
in the last four years accomplished
major things
now in terms of a personal style he's
been divisive
all i can say is that many of us on the
conservative side believe that the
coverage of president trump
has been over the top i was here during
the
the obama years a good example
the mueller investigation you covered
breathlessly
turned out not to be the event that it
was built to be
and when we looked at the abuse at
department of justice and the fbi
you found it in the obituary page
that fox no you all covered it for the
most part
uh that's the double standard i think
that the problems that hunter biden have
if a trump had done those things would
be front page news everywhere
so there's a lot of people on my side of
the aisle
who believe that the president the way
he's been covered is contributed to a
lot of
discourse and
you all have lost the mainstream media
conservative america and you gotta ask
why what concerns do you have with the
way that capitol hill police
uh handled the protest last night and
should their 460
um million dollar budget be reviewed
okay
one think the front line officers how
could we not be prepared how could in a
joint session of congress with the vice
president in the building
you not do better than this where were
the national guard
black lives matter protest have you seen
the images on the capitol steps
where we had national guard members in
riot gear
why weren't you as prepared
this time around where was the pentagon
there's all kind of stories that they
were refusing to activate the dc
national guard i don't believe that to
be true
but what kind of intelligence gathering
apparatus does the capitol hill police
department
and the agencies in charge of defending
the capital have
how could they fail so miserably we're
20 years after 9 11
right yesterday they could have blown
the building up
they could have killed us all
they could destroy the government people
coming through the windows had backpacks
as big as my desk on the senate
they should have been challenged warning
shots should have been fired and lethal
force should have been used
once they penetrated the seat of
government
those backpacks could have had bombs
chemical agents weapons
we dodged a major bullet yesterday
if this is not a wake-up call i do not
know what is
is it a money problem if it is we'll fix
it
is it a leadership problem obviously is
it an intel
failure of the highest proportions
absolutely
so i will end where i began there are so
many story lines for the last 48 hours
many of them political this one has
brought us together
bernie sanders was as upset with what
happened as i was
i was talking with bernie about how
could they come in and take over the
senate
and he said get them out of there
to his credit bernie wanted a forceful
response
to the domestic terrorist who occupied
the house and the senate so let's end on
this note
yesterday the capital of the united
states
was taken over by domestic terrorists
that are not patriots they overwhelmed
the capitol police
they destroyed the house
they took over the place and sat in the
presiding officer's chair
they went through my desk and all of us
had to go
to a single room to be protected
this shall never happen again we've lost
our will and our determination to stand
up for law and order
and when you let a courthouse be
attacked and nobody
gets prosecuted the next thing you know
it gets worse
to all the mayors out there who have dis
accord and
law unlawful behavior in your city get
on top of it
i'm not a mayor i'm a united states
senator i accept responsibility
for fixing this problem how do you fix
this problem
you adequately resource those in charge
of defense
you hold those accountable
and if they fail you fire them and you
prosecute
prosecute the law breaker all of these
images
of people sitting in these chairs and
pelosi's
speaker's chair i mean office chair
we know who that person is they should
go from sitting in the speaker's chair
to a jail cell thank you